Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange focus channel.
My name is Paul.
Today I'm going to be talking about a
language learning tool called memorize.
I tend to be a traditional kind of
learner.
I focus on using textbooks on audio
listening materials are not
communicating with native speakers.
Those are the staples of my typical
study routine,
but a lot of people ask me about things
like memorize.
So I decided to give,
memorize a try and give you my review
and tell you my impression.
So first of all,
what is memorize?
Well,
memorize is a language learning platform
that's available on your desktop
computer or on your smartphone.
And it is basically a system for
memorizing using flashcards with a
spaced repetition system.
So it's similar to something like
[inaudible] in which you use a flashcard
and to learn a word and then you review
it at graduated intervals.
Those intervals get longer each time you
review the word,
so maybe the first time you review it
two minutes later,
but then after that the next review
comes 10 minutes later,
the next one comes 30 minutes later,
that kind of thing.
So you're increasing the interval
between the reviews of the flashcard
each time.
That's what I mean by a spaced
repetition system memorizes used
primarily for language learning,
but you can use it for other kinds of
information to like geography or biology
or whatever information you could put on
flashcards.
You can make flashcards and use them in
the memorized system.
One of the pillars of the memorize
approach is science.
They claim to have a lot of legitimate
science behind their approach behind
their technology with one of the
founders of memorize being a
neuroscientist and the other one being
an award winning master of memory,
someone who's won a lot of memory
contests,
that kind of thing.
The science of memorize focuses on two
things in coding and testing.
So the first thing that memorize is
focused on is encoding new information
into your memory.
And that is done by using something
called memes.
What memes are is they are kind of
multimedia bits of information that can
help you connect to that new information
to something you already know.
So it could be an image.
So you're associating that new phrase or
a word with an image that is familiar to
you.
It could be a funny sentence or a
shocking sentence,
something like that.
It could be a mnemonic device.
Any of these kinds of things that can
help you connect that new information,
make some connections and retrieve that
memory later.
Those can be used as memes.
If you're an experienced language
learners,
and you might be good at coming up with
memes of your own off the top of your
head,
but if you're not,
or if you just need extra ideas,
then you get these memes within the
memorize system that are provided for
you.
So those memes are for the purpose of
encoding new information into memory.
The second scientific principle that
memorize this,
focused on his testing.
So after you have encoded that new
information as a memory,
then the next thing is to test yourself.
That is to prompt yourself to recall
that information later on before you
forget it.
And when you do recall that information,
that strengthens the memory.
Okay,
next I'll talk about the content.
And by that I mean the courses and the
flashcards that you can learn from
inside the memorized system.
Memorize content is organized into
courses and each of those courses
consists of a bunch of flashcards and
those courses are created by memrise
users.
They're not created by the founders of
memorize or their employees,
the created by you,
the people who use memorize.
So anyone who has the desktop version of
memorize can create a course anytime
they want.
And that means that there's a huge
variety of courses available.
There are tons of courses on memorize.
Okay,
so I'm going to talk about the positives
and the negatives of memorize.
And then after that I'll give you my
final thoughts in summary on this tool
for language learning.
So the positives,
number one is just the sheer number of
courses available.
The amount of content on memorize is
staggering.
If you look at the courses available at
the languages available,
there's just tons and tons to choose
from.
So it's like being a kid in a candy
store.
It's really a lot of fun just to browse
through there and think about what
course do you want to try next.
So let's take a look at the selection
inside.
Memorize plumps.
Here we are on the memorize homepage,
and if I click on the courses button
over here,
we'll see some of the featured courses
on the front page.
So we have learned basic Russian learn,
basic Brazilian,
that et Cetera.
So at least ones are particularly
popular.
So they are featured on the front page,
but these are not the only language
courses available.
Let's look at the left hand sidebar and
see some of the others.
So this is,
these are the top categories,
the most popular languages,
but look down below that and we can look
at all categories.
So you see there are some other subjects
like Trivia and memory training,
history,
geography.
But let's look at languages looked at
that.
We've got all languages or language is
broken down into regions.
So let's click on for example,
African and see how many languages there
are.
You can see there's a big long list of
African languages,
Zulu,
Kosa,
Wallace,
Somali.
There's all these languages.
Let's have a look up above at,
let's see,
Asian and Pacific.
Let's see.
So a lot of the Asian languages are
here.
Indonesian,
Korean,
Thai,
Vietnamese.
So even I knew even the,
I knew language from Japan,
which is a very endangered language even
nowadays.
So there's a lot of languages that are
much less widely studied that courses
are available for it.
Let's choose a language and click on it
just to see the variety of courses that
you can get just for that one language.
So let's click,
let's not click the top one because that
would be too obvious.
Let's click,
let's see,
how about Italian?
Let's go for that.
So we've got learn basic Italian,
I don't know exactly what it consists
of,
but it says learn Italian vocab and
grammar verbs,
phrases.
And down here,
let's see,
intermediate,
Italian,
Italian verbs and expressions,
introductory Italian,
the 500 most common Italian verbs,
hacking,
Italian,
elementary,
Italian.
So these are all different courses by
users.
Some of them might cover similar things,
so you probably don't want to do all of
the courses,
but there's a lot to choose from,
which is part of the fun of looking
around inside memorize,
so you don't have to start at the
beginning and follow a linear path with
any kind.
Of course,
you can jump around and skip around a
little bit.
You can do multiple courses at the same
time.
It's really up to you.
It's nice to have that flexibility.
Okay.
The second positive thing is that the
system of encoding and testing,
it's quite effective in my opinion.
I tried out some to gallows and French
courses,
but I also tried out a Turkish course
because Turkish is a language that I've
never studied and I got a chance to see
how it feels to learn a language from
scratch using memorize.
I didn't get really,
really far with that course.
I just did a few lessons in it,
but I had a chance to see how well I
remembered things and I felt that I
remembered the words quite well because
I was prompted to recall the words at
times when I was just about to forget
them.
And that's actually really good in
spaced repetition and the goal is that
you want to retrieve the word right
before you forget it because the more
effort it takes to recall and retrieve
that word,
the the more you will strengthen that
memory.
So it felt like the memorize system had
really strategically timed when I needed
to review that word right on the edge of
forgetting it,
which is good.
I also found the memes quite useful.
I'm an experienced language learner.
I'm pretty good at coming up with my own
memes.
But having a bunch of crowdsourced memes
to choose from makes it just really easy
and quick.
And sometimes you see one that really
you connect with and you want to use
more than your own,
and that just makes everything easier
and smoother.
So so there,
why not?
It's useful.
Okay.
So now for a couple of negative things,
the first negative point is that
memorize is not really a comprehensive
language learning system.
It's basically a flashcard drilling
system with spaced repetition.
So it's not something I would use to
learn a language completely from scratch
all by itself.
You don't really get any explanation
about the grammar or phonology or
anything like that.
So sometimes when it's practicing with
memorize,
I would be looking at a word and
thinking why are the letters pronounced
this way?
I would,
I really would like to have some
explanation of the phonology or things
like that.
But of course there is none.
So I'm pretty good at to do sing that
stuff from examples just from
experience.
And that's the way I think.
But I think a lot of people really need
to have that explanation.
And even for me,
it's good to have it.
It makes it easier.
So just the lack of explanation and that
was the lack of presentation of the
language concepts makes it less than a
full language learning course.
It's really just drilling vocabulary of
phrases and translation of sentences.
So that means that basically you should
use memorize along with another course
that is more comprehensive.
Okay.
The second negative thing is that the
user generated courses are both a
blessing and a curse.
Like I said before,
they're a blessing because there's such
an,
an awesome amount of variety and such a
selection to choose from.
But at the same time,
there's not really a lot of quality
control and there's no standardization
of the courses.
Some of them are a lot better than
others.
Some of them seem to introduce words in
a really strange order or they start
with things that in the beginning that
you don't need yet and that kind of
stuff.
So I found that I really had to search
around and try a few different courses
to see which one fit my needs and then
if it didn't fit my needs,
just leave that course and join a
different one.
So you have to look around,
shop around a little bit before you
decide what course to use.
So that's a little bit different than
some other language learning platforms
that have been kind of refined and
standardized more so that you kind of
always know that you're getting a course
that they themselves have developed and
focused on.
Basically to sum up my positives and
negatives,
I would say that memorize is actually a
really useful tool for drilling
vocabulary and for drilling sentences
and maybe doing some sentence to
sentence translation and it's a fun tool
to use so it's good as a supplement.
It's good to get that extra source of
input of the language.
It's just a useful tool but it's not a
comprehensive language learning program
so I wouldn't stick to only memorize
unless you're just dabbling in a
language on the side.
Like if you're focused on French and you
want to learn a bit of Portuguese,
then just use memorize.
For some Portuguese that would be fine.
But if you are really taking a language
seriously,
I would have a comprehensive main course
and then use memorize as an extra
additional helpful tool,
which it is.
So that's all from my impressions.
But how about you?
Have you tried memorize?
If you have,
then I ask you to leave your comments
down below.
Tell me what you thought of it,
was it useful for you?
And if you have some tips on how to use
it more effectively,
then please write that as well.
Thank you very much for watching the
langue focus channel.
Be sure to follow lane,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
instagram,
and Google.
Plus.
I'll be looking forward to interacting
with you and all of those different
places.
All right.
Have a good day.